mcdonald
oh how are you oh so who's this it's
trevor
trevor yeah sorry my i i work at kelly
tolton so
um i've been asking leon um about
a player that we could maybe look to
partner with
and he recommended he recommended you
with the success you've had
and like you're very promising player
and congratulations on making the north
team by the way
oh shoot thank you appreciate that
you're well deserved you've had a hell
of a season
yeah it's been um it's been pretty full
on yeah mate you're on yeah but it's
good thank you
see the blues actually winning yeah for
sure mate
it's been a while but you're doing well
have you been there pretty well
yeah well actually thanks for asking but
we're actually really struggling at the
moment with
covert and oh yeah so um this is the
issue so we're
um we're in a pretty bad situation we've
got all the sea animals
and we're a little bit we're a little
we're looking to sort of
end up our marketing so um
we've been brainstorming for weeks and
that's when we thought we might be a
good chance to tap into the blues
success
and your success personally so um
what you have any thoughts on that would
you be interested in maybe partnering up
with kelly toltens
yeah 100 bro anything to help i'd love
to i'd love to
come and help you guys out will be
partnered with you do you um
yeah do you love sea animals yep i love
fishing oh
not no yeah i love fishing again i like
loving on the water burn i love
um uh animals and everything awesome
you like killing the animals or you like
oh no
that's
i love everything you know with your
color challenge i remember going there
when i was young and i loved it
and all my um all my all my little
cousins literally i think was
really the start of this status yeah or
was it last year that we should
see they went through there they all
they all loved it so now i'll be i'll be
happy he has to join
up with you guys mate because what we're
thinking is sort of making you the face
of the
uh whole aquarium and changing our name
from kelly tolton's to kelly
daltons oh actually
yeah would you be interested oh they'll
be awesome
kelly daltons would be i think it might
be just that we
secret that we need to um get back on
the board you know
yeah oh man i'd love to yeah i'd love to
join you guys be partners with you yeah
as long as you don't go killing our sea
creatures
oh no no no way no way
oh no oh thanks for the opportunity by
the way and oh what would be
would be looking to give you sort of um
like unlimited access
to kelly tolton so you could visit it 20
times a day if you want it
oh shoot that'll be awesome oh awesome
so oh that'd be
cool man um so yeah change your name
kelly daltons
you get unlimited access um you could
even bring some mates or maybe half
price and stuff so
we'll just have an awesome time and grow
the partnership
yeah oh 100 yeah so is this is this your
number yeah this is my number
oh okay three days so oh awesome
awesome delta appreciate this because
i'm with all
with all the lockdown i'm up with
lockdown when lockdown goes down i'll
begin to meet up and
uh go over more in detail with um with
what i can do and where you guys can do
it for me and with our partnership all
right
perfect let's do that
yep so i'll say i'll save your numbers
trevor trevor yeah
okay sweetheart all good sweet thanks
mate yeah yep
all right see you nice to see you thank
you thanks all right keep in touch but
yeah
all day bye
uh